I want to ask this question because
maybe it's a little philosophical what
do you think drives this anti-human bent
in these people Schwab Bill Gates the
the demons Gravity the pain of being
sucked down to a planet the pain the
physical pain that we we've become
desensitized to makes people hate
themselves to answer your question I I
think there's a combination of of
satanists demons people with mental
health issues but but more consensus
more more
um in a more simple way throughout human
history there has always been someone
trying to conquer the world that's not
something that's out of the ordinary it
is the norm whether it's Genghis Khan
Napoleon Caesar whoever it may be they
become so empowered by other individuals
that that power corrupts them absolute
power corrupts absolutely and these
individuals have reached such power such
wealth that the they are going along
with what Hitler did with what Mao did
what Stalin did trying to conquer and
control human life for their own
personal benefits sociopathic demons is
one easy way to describe them another
way another way to describe them is of
course just saying throughout human
history there have always been these
types of people that challenge us and
try to conquer everything yeah Alexander
the Great he was on a conquering spree
going east taking like all of you know
what is it Ursa Minor that East uh
Western Asia and it got to the point
where he conquered so much of Persia
maybe even all of Persia and then his
generals were like okay Alex we've had
enough we we want to go home to see our
wives it's been 15 years you promised
you know this is all about making our
lives better and Alex is like we must go
on we must continue and they fought and
he kept taking them they're like we're
done and then one day Alexander woke up
and he was very sick from the night
before I think they poisoned him I mean
the theory is that his General's poison
because they couldn't they couldn't stop
him once you get into that state of mind
got conquering and he thought he was the
son of God like he was like educated by
Aristotle his mother told him he was a
God and a god manly he thought he was
there to conquer Earth and the only way
to stop someone like that at least to
his generals was he had to stop him
because he wasn't going to stop why do
you think well yeah I don't know I do
think it's a spiritual battle kind of
that you alluded to that you know if if
we were created by God we're Made In His
Image you know and there is a Satan you
know you have to assume that that he
hates the image of God you know we he he
he despises us and and I think if you
know if those forces are at work in the
world then there's always going to be
those people who rise up and and who
kind of just naturally hate hate God's
image you know the on the earth and and
so it's probably kind of his oldest time
like you said
just takes different iterations you know
through it throughout history
there's always some jerk taking a dump
in the punch bowl it's got to be like
and that's history like fear of being
attacked like what zielinski was saying
we need to preemptively strike so that
they don't attack us like what the
Romans did we need to conquer everyone
around us so that we don't get attacked
because if you actually are attacked and
your city's sacked like Rome happened to
roam in the early days there's like 200
years to recover from that like it can
annihilate a civilization if you're
attacked so there's this idea of like I
need to conquer the Earth so that the
Earth doesn't conquer me do you think
we're bored too we just we're so
comfortable and happy and we have
everything we need and it mankind gets
to a point where they just get bored and
we just have to destroy something so we
can build it up again life used to be
about survival right 80 90 of your day
was just wake up work otherwise you
don't have food winter is coming are you
ready
now we've got heating Refrigeration we
can have strawberries in the dead of
winter we can have avocados fresh
tableside guacamole prepared to order in
January now that's something to behold
so it's just we just we you know they
talk about like we got to end Global
poverty and blah blah blah and I'm like
I get it but there's no such thing as
ending poverty because even the poorest
people in the world have access to
technologies that were Unthinkable a
hundred years ago not that they have
like consistent access to it but even
the United States the poorest person in
the US can get clean drinking water very
very easily you walk into a McDonald's
and you're like water you're good try
doing that in some other parts of the
world where there's no water and they're
desperate yeah well I don't think that
also explains it because throughout
human history when there was no drinking
water tribes used to kill other tribes
whether it was Native Americans whether
it was Europeans there was always
someone trying to kill someone else for
their resources for for their clean
water for their food and for their you
know energy and ability to survive as
well so this has been happening for a
very very long time now it's it only
gets a lot more sophisticated it only
gets a lot more complicated because of
these technological advancements that
allow people to hide behind the scenes
and to impose their will in a fifth
generational Warfare away where people
don't even realize that they're being
depopulated that they're being
chemically attacked that they're being
castrated that they're being taught and
manipulated in a way that they become
self-destructive and Destroy themselves
as a would-be dictator is literally
pulling the strings and calling the
shots without anyone even knowing their
name I think that's a more likely
scenario with what we're dealing with
right now than previously in archaic
times where you would stab someone and
you would go into battle now the battle
I think is in our minds and I think that
battle is expanding in a way that that
there's no denying that it exists
especially with the dehumanization that
we have seen within the last few years
yeah I was thinking about the ballistics
and how they've changed War like being
able to not have to look your enemy in
the eye when you kill them but then I'm
thinking about the Romans and how they
basically genocided the Gauls they went
through all of France and just millions
of people were slaughtered at the hands
of the Romans and I think it gets to the
point where the killers enjoy killing
like they they learn the dehumanize
these things that they're attacking and
they enjoy the abusive Behavior like
it's a powerful rush you gain from it
you get food and money and jewels and
women after you make the kill and it's
like addictive and and and and when it
becomes easy for them yeah and they
think about you know these people have
ideas I don't like hey
it's just that much easier they don't
think of as people too it's so crazy how
the dehumanization can happen when you
just call them savage or whatever you
want yeah I'm telling you they treat us
like chickens
look this is what I was saying this
earlier today on my other show the
government deeply cares about you your
government cares about you they care
about your well-being and they want you
to be healthy and happy
in so far as you can provide labor for
them everything else your love your life
your your your faith your dreams
completely meaningless right right and
if you get in the way of their labor
machine you are expendable so they care
about you as much as I care about say
chickens like I don't want harm to
befall them but if I have to get rid of
you know a Cocky Rooster he's going out
to cocktown or he's getting chopped up
for lunch they give me eggs I don't care
what else they do in the meantime but if
they start doing things I don't like
then you go in and you deal with them
that's how they view people we provide
labor we do work it allows them to live
in their Elysium golden towers with
golden toilets but if we start acting
out of line speaking up and challenging
their Authority the reality is we aren't
chickens we are humans and humans are
smart smart enough so if there are smart
people who can challenge them at the top
that's a problem I got nothing to worry
about there's zero chance Roberto Jr is
going to figure out how to come in here
and take this company over he's a
rooster near zero chance near zero
chance there's a small percentage for
human beings when we do shows like this
the people who are currently whole
holding the keys to the chicken coop in
which we are all imprisoned they have to
be careful because people are smart
enough to break free from that and that
means you ain't getting eggs anymore
that's why we have politics because
people are too smart so we need a mind
control system to utilize their
intelligence without allowing them
to seize control and that's possibly why
we've seen such a ramp up with with
what's happening globally in the you
know the great reset and all this Wars
is because of the information age what's
happened you know this has been this is
the Advent of the printing press you
know with the internet we now have all
this access to information without
Gatekeepers and so it it's it does seem
like kind of the powers that be are very
violently reacting to that boy do they
regret that one yeah oh yeah but to add
to your point in talking about politics
I think politics is just there to
placate the population I think it's
there to just convince people that they
actually have a say in things when they
actually don't it's it's like a
Fisher-Price toy that you give to a
child that you just distract them with
thinking that they're actually cooking a
meal when they're actually not I think
that our political system has run the
same exact way and there's powerful
people behind the scenes calling the
shots getting whatever they want
convincing you brainwashing you and
screwing you over every single day and
they're doing it more than ever and
there was even a Mainline study that we
talked about a couple years ago I think
on this show specifically talking about
how our form of government is a joke it
doesn't exist we don't live under a
democracy we don't have a democracy
because special interests always get
their way what people want never happens
it's the top plutonomy it was the
plutocracy I think no plutonomy was the
report I think it was from Citigroup
okay yeah they said the United States is
not a democracy it's a plutonomy where
the wealthiest control the system yeah a
great example of that is super delegates
the Democratic party no matter who votes
for what when you go to the polls at the
very end the super delicate company like
actually we're going to make Joe Biden
the nominee like you're not voting for
The nominee you're voting for people
that you hope will nominate the person
you want them to vote for it's not
democracy in the slightest I like this
plutonomy yeah this is the documents the
plutonomy PDF Citigroup Equity strategy
plutonomy buying luxury expanding Global
explaining Global imbalances the world
is dividing into two blocks the
plutonomy and the rest the U.S UK and
Canada are the key plutonomies economies
powered by the wealthy Continental
Europe ex Italy and Japan are the
egalitarian Bloc Equity risk premium
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah the
plutonomy machine economy is driven by
the wealthy that's China right now the
industrial wealth wealth is distribution
wealth is production it does not about
how many dollars you have it's about
what you're producing and the Chinese
people are producing like mad at the
moment we're producing a lot of paper
money so there's that yeah that's good
true yeah we've chosen a private company
to do that for us at their own
discretion the Federal Reserve yeah yeah
plutonomy is a term that refers to the
science of the production of
distribution of wealth in modern times
Citigroup analysts beginning with AJ
Kapoor in 2005 have used the term
describing economy in which the rich are
the driving forces and Main
beneficiaries of economic growth others
including Noam Chomsky have used the
term to refer to a nation or economy in
which wealth is concentrated in the
hands of a few
and there you go that's where you are
and then they can use that for Access
for lobbying for manipulation for media
control and then they create little
underlings to go on Twitter and lie to
you and know they lie to you and that's
it it's just some people are just
evil yeah I was thinking about this when
they I saw uh some that can't remember
what I was watching but they were like
Republicans are trying to bring about
evil into this country or whatever and
then I thought about that I'm like well
they know that's not serious like these
these people know that they're the ones
who are lying because there's no way you
can believe every single Lie from the
mainstream media unless you know like
there's no way you can keep saying this
and believe these lies unless there's
something wrong with you or you're just
pushing the lies
and so what I think is they view freedom
and liberty as chaos and evil whereas we
view authoritarianism and manipulation
evil so to them they're like these
people are evil they want just chaos
people doing everything and then it all
burns down in climate change and
whatever I picture them like the guy in
the basement that paints the little you
know figures and nothing nothing wrong
with that but like you know that has the
has the the the scenes set up and
everything just so and everything pose
maybe like a little train set or
something like that and you know imagine
if those Figures were about to you know
have agency or free will and it's just
the guy loses his mind that's kind of
they're they're people tinkering with a
with a train set in their basement
that's obsessed with order yeah
Libertarians are obsessed with chaos
maybe not but I mean if you become
obsessed with chaos or order you become
very dangerous there there's gotta be a
balance yeah there it does because too
much order is show me your papers or get
in the cell too much chaos is I lit it
on fire I don't even know where the fire
is anymore yeah well the really great
and and really bad thing about our
current dichotomy is that in this larger
War people are are literally killing and
taking themselves out
um it's it's a really bad thing because
it's horrible to see and you try to
prevent it but but a lot of times it's
very difficult to do so but on another
aspect it's a good thing because at the
same time it could be stopped just by
information just by knowledge just by
people being able to talk to each other
in a transparent accountable full honest
real truthful way and the internet
provides us a small opportunity to do
that but it's being limited every single
day because of that particular reason
this is why this this move by Twitter
again it's going to be interesting to
see how it plays out but uh I think it
provides a huge potential that could
really upend and shift things will it
happen I'm skeptical but I I do see it
as something that could change the world
for the better as people realize hey
maybe I shouldn't be hurting myself
maybe I shouldn't be treating myself bad
maybe I should start eating better maybe
I should start working out maybe I
shouldn't just listen and do everything
that they tell me to do and I keep
getting screwed over by it and I think
the more people who have those
conversations and and actually open
themselves up to fixing themselves they
won't be killing themselves and blowing
themselves up figuratively mentally
speaking Yeah drug addiction like uh and
I'm talking about high fructose corn
syrup sugars well types of drugs like
that something the government can't
really kind of control by Banning
certain substances but the whole like
obesity epidemic because like you were
saying earlier the government wants
workers they want chickens they just do
their chicken thing and lay the eggs but
then why are they letting people get
obese I don't think that I think it's
just it's bigger than gut like economy
is is the market is stronger than our
government thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there